Los partidarios del actual mandatario
Turco muestran signos de Victoria su
candidatura Jetta giberdoan está cerca
del 50% pero no evitará una segunda
vuelta la primera en 20 años desde que
es presidente sin embargo su
simpatizantes reafirman su confianza
hacia su líder
estoy segura de que erdogan ganará creo
que conseguirá los votos de sinalogan
con un poco más del 5% de los votos sin
anudar el candidato ultranacionalista se
postula como una pieza clave y será del
centro de atención en los próximos días
de momento no ha anunciado a quien
apoyará en el balotaje en la Esfera
opositora Los partidarios de quemala
mantiene la esperanza de que su
candidato gane el 28 de mayo Aunque
algunos prevén una compañía más difícil
esta vez no soy muy optimista creo que
podemos ganar en la segunda vuelta pero
tengo mucho miedo de lo que pueda pasar
en las próximas dos semanas
en el legislativo
su mayoría parlamentaria en los comicios
que también se celebraron el domingo
esta Victoria podría constituir una base
importante en el resultado de la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
en un país poco acostumbrado al poder
compartido entre El Ejecutivo y el
legislativo